hello freak [ __ ] they rebranded it as
Chilean sea bass and pedaled it as
gourmet fare scam so disappointing real
talk real talk that's a lot don't you
think I've got enough [ __ ] on my
mind yeah you gotta press your head
my favorite is [ __ ] I wish you would
the [ __ ] we all wish someone would
burn your clothes our Kelly they're
disgusting I love it think it's more
like don't you know how many sexual
harassment lawsuits I have on my mind
like what is how Kelly have on his mind
does he have a lot on his plate I don't
think he's like remarkably calm yeah all
this old is art Kelly he's 80
he seems to be like gliding 35 for 78
years he seems to be gliding through any
forms of controversy like relatively you
have oh god bleep thumbs it's 57 and 50
this year 50 Wow um how much money is he
worth 20 million way more hundred
million does write his own songs or
whatever the [ __ ] else is true he's got
probably 150 million stored in his
[ __ ] basement somewhere these
constant shows it's live shows you're
right you're right you're right
sells out giant places every time you
sell out a giant website is towards
hundreds constantly touring I think
tours he turns a lot when he's not
[ __ ] Oh
events that's a beautiful photograph is
a roomy arena [ __ ]
arena you know why I do in Ontario I do
the [ __ ] improv it's a fun one
Citizens Bank Arena that's like a twenty
thousand see how much tickets 50 bucks
50 bucks okay
the after-party tour so no one's mad no
one's mad about Oh 127 bucks
damn Real Talk [ __ ] you [ __ ] you ok girl
do you know a good point you know what
never mind
I'll stop yelling that was a cogent
point he's um he's still raking him in
he does those every now and then rakes
in the cash goes back to his sex slave
den slangs until he falls asleep so do
you have to pay to me in the sex cult
yeah everybody with your integrity and
everybody in sexual health everybody
pays go listen to motional gonna take
notes 50 years old 150 million dollars
goddamn it sold over a hundred million
albums wow it's amazing he's only got a
hundred fifty million left what he's got
a dollar an album that's crazy you got
to get a new man pretty good he saved
that much for a dollar now it was pretty
good yeah he would just think that guy
that plus concert sales like he just
maybe he's got a lot more money I mean
you know those [ __ ] people don't know
that celebrity network they just making
guesses so I was gonna say what is that
based on I've gone to mine and it's not
true I don't think I literally have no
idea seems you to support her ex are
kelly is are Kelly's ex-wife he agreed
to a fifty million dollar settlement
with his ex-wife were they married more
than ten years there must have been whoa
because in California you get to
choreograph from blah blah blah and she
auditioned to be one of his backup
dancers in 1994 they married in 96 they
had three children divorced in 2000 nots
yeah since then he has gone on a dick
slinging epic proportion the singer
explained the grounds of their divorce
in his 2012 autobiography Sola coaster
the diary of me why the diary why did
you think my diary no not the diary of
me you maniac sir it's been a solar
coaster it's been a solar coast I'm
uncomfortable I'm here
you know that you can just say my diet
right so the coaster why would anyone
look so awesome look at all those
microphones pointing at them what is
that he's hot lying that looks like the
cover of the rosetta stone it's like
maybe the greatest book of all time 189
consumer reviews in four and a half
[ __ ] stars that's what I'm saying I'm
seeing success yes do you know that
Matthew McConaughey's mother has a book
it's called I amaze myself paid out
millions and out-of-court sexual
misconduct settlements Ryuto Hey I mean
he's fining people that like to live his
way do you think you could start a cult
you kind of have a call actually I think
pretty much anybody get Starbucks I know
some a shitty comedian that's basically
started a cult
yeah I'll write it down okay it's it's
more common than you would think
I think like people have yeah yeah that
one Wow um I think there's I think
there's a lot of people that want to be
led I think there's a lot of people that
like just how some people are born tall
I mean how joke about this like well
it's trying to explain to my kid
something yeah and I was like you know
some people have big ears and some
people have little ears well some people
have brains that are made out of dog
[ __ ] yeah
I mean you find people that are dumber
than them that let them have sex with
them yeah and then they make kids and
those kids are [ __ ] and don't let
anybody tell you any different and if
you have a really low watt brain and you
run into some charismatic figure that
you you you feel didn't we just see this
happen in November yeah there's a lot of
that yeah I mean that's I mean that's
what a lot of what happened right a lot
of people who yes you [ __ ] that's
your president to you piece of [ __ ] well
down real talk yeah you can there's a
lot of monkeys out there
[Applause]
[Music]